la bataille était jusqu'au bout jusqu'à
la dernière manche avec guillaume du
caire qui gagnent la semaine nautique
les conditions étaient vraiment vraiment
avec beaucoup beaucoup de vent une
moyenne de 25 noeuds et c'était
compliqué j'irai tout avec les nouvelles
voies les plus grosses voile
donc c'était chaud dans sa catégorie des
bagarres belle bagarre
les deux premiers mois et guillaume
buquet justement les jours soit il
passait devant moi je passais devant la
halle a gagné la dernière manche dans
qui passe devant une belle bagarre
jusqu'au bout j'ai bien aimé bataille et
voilà ah oui c'était vraiment difficile
puisque à la dernière manche on est
encore à égalité avec kilian on connaît
en revanche ça a été vraiment une belle
bataille sur l'eau et c'était vraiment
agréable pour retenez-vous de semaine a
été vraiment dur
il ya eu des conditions assez musclées
beaucoup de vent donc c'est la semaine
nautique serment une compétition assez
dur il nous faut vraiment travailler le
physique qui permet vraiment de voir son
nom
au point niveau physique donc à ses
enfants une très belle expérience un bon
niveau technique et beaucoup de vent moi
ça m'a favorisé je suis plutôt à l'aise
quand il ya du vent
donc je suis plutôt content maintenant
l'heure c'est finir le championnat de
martinique avec les manches qui restent
et à viser le championnat de france
la semaine était difficile parce que le
premier jour j'ai cassé d'élèves de ma
planche donc j'ai dû réparer ce hollow
et ça m'a fait perdre environ 10 places
et la deuxième jour ça s'est bien passé
j'ai crise a rattrapé malgré un faux
départ
hier j'ai
un accident avec sébastien aux dépens
donc j'ai dû abandonner la manche parce
que c'était assez violent et ma planche
s'est cassé aujourd'hui ça allait j'ai
cassé j'ai eu le temps de rattraper le
troisième au général de prendre sa place
parce qu'il y avait un peu plus de vent
il est un peu moins fort dans le vent et
ça c'est juste la tactique et la vitesse
les guadeloupéens et les martiniquais en
général sont plus forts que ceux de
l'équipe de france dans le vent passe on
a l'habitude de s'entraîner dans ces
conditions le plus chaud en 130 sur des
lacs ou haute et on est un peu plus
lourd aussi donc on arrive à mieux tenir
dans le vent